how much of this do you feel is a show
in this is a mockery of Pro fighting hey
Aria for BuzzFeed
posting questions please that's what I'm
saying question no one has a single
question I got a question for someone
who works at a media company I am still
embarrassingly baffled by a youtuber and
influencer culture in a world driven by
social media and followers these
personalities are able to build these
almost cult-like fandoms that will
basically buy into anything they do and
we have a perfect example here in LA in
a few days when youtubers ksi and logan
paul square off in a boxing rematch at
the Staples Center and what it's not
only going to be a viral event but what
is sure to be a huge payday for the both
of them I'm gonna be straight up front
with you now how much of this do you
feel it is a show in terms of you know
show I believe they're there meaning
everywhere they say they want to end the
other they want to show that they are
number one I you know I don't believe
that any of that is set up probably
reason why I'm particularly invested in
this project is that earlier this year I
trained and fought in an amateur MMA
fight I remember speaking and
interviewing these different fighters
who made it very clear that a fighters
life is a very poor one I have made
$0.00 fighting
moving on to getting paid or maybe
barely breaking even is is what I want
to do you train twice a day three times
a day every day for months years on end
and you still might not even get your
break there's no money in this stuff you
know it's enough to keep the lights on
that's cool
I feel for them in a way when I hear
about fighters that have come out and
criticized Logan Pawlenty aside I
finally almost insulting to everybody
that has dedicated their life to being a
fire come up the hard way and these two
come in there they're almost making a
mockery out of the sport in many ways I
feel like this whole event is kind of
emblematic of my rights against
influencer culture where these two
popular personalities can just throw
themselves at Staples Center in a main
event in a sport where people have spent
their entire lives toiling
for a dream that these two guys got to
live out for pure entertainment value
and possibly a quick buck I know you
kind of disagree though jack right I
don't fully disagree I completely get
what you're saying and I understand
people's frustrations but if they have
the fans in the popularity to sell out
the Staples Center like why shouldn't
they I do understand why guys who've
dedicated their whole lives to something
could feel frustrated that in a way
these guys are jumping the queue most of
the high level of boxers today they
started by junior high school if not
earlier I'm anxious to see you know what
they can do and how they look
we have passes so we're gonna get a
closer look at things the other fighters
on the cart are getting in first I think
as the Sun sets and the night goes on
eventually ksi and logo Paul will be in
there five bands just pulled up so it's
a big squad coming in I was lucky in
this is quite a Ford gathered here
well Logan Paul got into the ring the
first thing I noticed was that he drops
his job he's really kind of like quick
it is very common in early fighters
you're leaving your face open for the
right hand so look they got the foam
pads the coach is clearly missing wide
and showing it what's coming I would not
be happy about this
if I were the coach fight at this level
so at some point during Logan's workout
case I walked up on to the corner that's
something that wouldn't be allowed
unless they were looking to have a
confrontation I don't think I've ever
seen it happen in an open work out it's
usually at the faceoff
[Music]
publicity stunt if you didn't want that
to happen you would have kept ksi his
team back until Logan's team got out of
the ring increased the biggest thing
that I think was confirmed is that these
are not professional boxers his hips
turned all the way over mostly arm
punches his chins up in the air that's
very dangerous I thought it was very
unusual to see ksi come out with therapy
bands never seen a fighter I would even
call these guys decent amateur boxers
and I don't think it's fair to expect
them to be so you know it's not a knock
these guys look to me about whether you
look before you any mere fact they're
still very early in the learning curve
it's really not fair to be how
legitimate is it as a fight you know
it's not these are not two guys who
people should be paying 50 to $100 to
watch I mean this is a mockery of Pro
fighting I could see why Pro fighters
would be bitter about it but it's
evolution it's technology there's no
fighting social media that's become such
an essential part of our world this is
what it is it's two guys who are good at
getting an attention not two guys who
are good at boxing I mean if you
consider it's a nothing fight I mean
these dudes they don't know how to fight
let's be clear about that
they have promoted it very well like I
know good fight promotion when I see it
it stirs it now we're two days out from
the fight that we're here for the press
conference we brought along this thing
add some legitimacy and
using it but I guess there's a first
time for everything there's a boxing
look at this and say this is the
absolute worst thing that could happen
this is a sideshow one perspective I
didn't see until today was of course the
fact that yeah these are two youtubers
that are taking the top spot in a
professional boxing card but they are
bringing more eyes onto the sport
they're giving a platform for these
other fighters that will have millions
of eyes on it and is that a bad thing
for the sport we know that there's a
whole new audience come into this sport
on Saturday night and the aim for us is
to make sure that this audience yes to
fall in love with all the things that we
fell in love with with this sport boxing
but it doesn't matter what matters is
that they have sold a story
they're trying trying and they can
generate a huge audience
we've got been invited to go speak the
protocol I can't be too aggressive with
my question because if not they may just
take away our media pass hey aria from
BuzzFeed got be smart about it what you
need
hey Aria Nessun thank you for having us
do you help she's being with Logan it
was a lot different than I expected
despite what preconceived notions I had
of him he was a very nice guy cast aside
yeah sure don't mind I do they seemed
genuine you know sort of sort of done
with the fake [ __ ] I had that era on
YouTube where everything was clickbait
and I would just say things to say
things not anymore he's claimed that
after his past controversies that boxing
kind of saved him and that's something
that I kind of relate to right I mean
for a long time before I trained for my
fight I felt kind of directionless I
shot myself in the foot I was deep deep
deep in a dark hole and to be honest I
don't know what I would have done if I
quite literally didn't fight my way out
of it I mean you guys granted an
opportunity here that so many fighters
would dream to have do you take this
opportunity lightly absolutely not we're
both well aware of that it's why we've
been training as hard as we possibly can
boxing was it was slowing down a bit it
was there was the taxi business JJ and I
are very you gonna hurt you gonna get
beat up really bad I told me if you put
me in a press conference is wild the
coaches were going at it Logan and ksi
were going at it
momentum bit of a weird place right now
because I won't lie I was very very
entertained Jack you you having a great
time too you don't know anything when it
comes to anything don't strike me as a
dumb person at the end of the conference
they open it up for people to ask any
questions and what do you ask anything
no nobody questions all the room and I
definitely had my fair share questions
so I thought what the hell I got a
question I got questions this is a big
event main event Staples Center you guys
are fighting on the top of a card got
champion fighters on the card you guys
are make your pro debut do you guys feel
a sense of responsibility we put this
platform you've been given to the sport
and you feel you've earned your place
there at the top of the card I know what
it's like to be a pro fighter and it's
tall I you know I told myself I don't
have to do this but you know what I
realize
I've handed this you know I am a dog I'm
a fighter you're talking about guys that
had 20 million subscribers on YouTube
each know what these guys decide to do
is gonna be a big deal so they decided
to put on a fight why can't why should
we be mad at that I can tell you one
thing about it I've been covered in
combat sports for you know 15 years
that's the real thing what you did what
it looks like at that level earning
their keep and the reality is they're
not gonna turn this into some kind of
career you box anybody at a decent pro
level they're gonna them up and I take
it for what it is it's two guys you
train hard for something that they seem
to care a lot about people want to see
it your mother
provides you a wonderful surprise you
guys are here to see Logan Paul versus
ksi and you're a maverick as I can tell
your first time in the Staples Center
and you're here for Logan you came here
from Mexico for this yeah you guys are
big fans of your ki boy you don't really
care go away I mean it's crazy see there
are so many young kids here all right
Jack how are you feeling I'm good I'm
excited are you I'm looking forward to
the fight it's definitely a very
interesting cultural milestone to
youtubers to influencers at the top of a
professional boxing cart at the Staples
Center it's gonna be interesting night
for sure
all the time odd I just have exhausted
that was fun though they're not
professional fighters who do this for a
living
but the reality is they've gotten in
here they fought their hearts out and so
I do think they deserve you know more
credit than I gave them I think it's
kind of like your fight if you didn't
work for BuzzFeed would you have been
able to get the training you did or get
one of the main fights on the fight you
did I mean that was a big promotion
can't argue that I think it's all
perspective isn't it in the end right I
came into this week not caring about
these two guys I care about this fight
at all right but moments before the bell
rang when I saw them in the ring facing
each other I felt like you've got things
right we felt the exoti for that when I
stepped into the cage I remember the
nerves went away as soon as the bell
rang the nerves went away but the
moments leading up to it were just sexy
forever and I just felt those nerves
again for some reason tonight and I was
even finding your journey and your
experience are so recent that I think
it's not at all surprising that you were
able to kind of instantly identify with
what they were feeling it's a ring and
it's you and it's another guy and you
guys are going to head-to-head really
doesn't matter if there's one person
watching or a million people watching
you know you've got that again a little
bit without actually having to go in
there maybe that would get you back in
the gym there's no one big conclusion to
it all I think social media will always
have its pros and cons mm-hmm but I
guess I'd definitely leave this week
with a lot more respect for what they
did
weren't you gonna fight again if this
were a movie right now this would end
with me getting up out of this couch
walking over to my glove over there
taking it out of his case and then
coming to black box you tired to go up
there
[Music]